hi my name is Penn Badgley and I feel
the dull echo of imposter syndrome at
the prospect of being Conan O'Brien's
friend really yeah you feel like you'd
be an imposter why why do you say that
no so so in order for me to to even like
show up here in a way that's that's
enjoyable for anybody
um I I just like I have to be honest
about how
um surreal it it it is I mean I grew up
watching you and uh yes and you truly
are um it's just it's just I don't find
myself often feeling this way and and um
and it's and like I said when I when I
shook your hand it's it's an honor and I
just the more I listen to this show the
more I realize like
oh my God hold on a second Sona just
walked in this is this is good timing
yeah and this is uh of course this is
pen pen Sona Sona pen
uh yeah yeah right over here Sona
are you doing are you actually oh oh and
you know what's so oh Sony you know what
I love
um pen was just going on about what an
honor it is to meet me and you and yeah
you interrupted that and now it's
probably out of his head yeah no you're
welcome
I'm sorry uh
you know uh you're fine yeah you're okay
you don't need that kind of reason I was
loving it I'm self-confident I'm a fan
of this gentleman and I was liking I'll
I will say he was ladling a little bit
of gravy over me and I was enjoying
every second of it but I actually was
trying to not be flattering it's more
like um
it's surprisingly uh what's the word
yeah it's like an honor sounds like such
a platitude it's but it's it's it's uh
it's it's just it's just nice to be here
I guess well it's nice to have you here
it's nice to have you here and during
the pause you took I can get someone who
sounds like you to put in
um Godlike uh iconic you're such a
humble person Conan I have to tell you
yeah nobody sounds like
okay well isn't there some way Eduardo
isn't there some way that um during the
pause when Penn was thinking of what to
say no Eduardo be honest isn't there
some way we can manipulate defense voice
to say you are my hero
there's a way it won't be good but we
could explain that he choked on a chip
eating a pita chip at that moment and he
choked yeah uh and you are an
inspiration that's how Gorly sounds yeah
exactly I don't know why you turned into
Yoda all of a sudden
um quick timeout I'm hearing music
coming from a device oh oh my God Sona
I'm sorry
and when I told you this was going to be
the low point of your day you weren't
lying what is wrong with you the
flattery truly you come crashing in late
I didn't know you were recording and uh
yeah and what music were you listening
to I was actually I was listening to
Billy eilish okay well that's a good
choice she's enjoying my drive over here
and then I was having a really great day
until I walked into this room I swear to
God I thought I heard music but I I did
too I thought I've been gracious but I
swear to God I thought it was so
subliminal I thought I was falling in
love with Penn Badgley seriously like I
was looking at you and you were saying
these nice things to me and I heard
music this is what it's like I'm in love
with Penn Badgley which I you know I'm
sure a lot of people are you know what
maybe it wasn't my phone and maybe you
actually I feel like you are I'm talking
about him a lot